[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بايدن يصف الرد
الاسرائيلي في غزه بانه تجاوز الحد ويقول
انه يدفع بقوه من اجل التوصل الى وقف
مستدام للقتال يؤكد انه واقنع السيسي بعد
رفضه بفتح معبر رفح ومارس ضغوطا على
نتنياهو لايصال المساعدات الرئاسه المصريه
تؤكد انها فتحت معبر رفح منذ اللحظه
الاولى دون قيود او شروط لكن استمرار قصف
اسرائيل للمعبر حاله دون ادخال المساعدات
تجدون المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط
بالتعليق الاول وسائل اعلام تابعه لجماعه
انصار الله تقول ان قصفا امريكيا بريطانيا
جديدا استهدف مناطق عده في الح الحديده
والقياده الوسطى الامريكيه تعلن تنفيذ سبع
ضربات ضد زوارق مسيره وصواريخ قالت ان
الجماعه كانت تستعد لاطلاقها طهران تقول
ان وقف الهجوم الاسرائيلي على غزه سيهي
الظروف لاستعاده الاستقرار بالبحر الاحمر
منظمه العفو الدوليه تقول ان السلطات
الهنديه تنفذ عمليات هدم تعسفيه لممتلكات
المسلمين ضمن اشكال ما وصفته بالعقاب
الجماعي لهذه الاقليه واضافت ان عمليات
الهدم المعروفه شعبيا باسم عداله الجرافات
ادت الى تشريد العديد من المسلمين لكنها
حظيت بالترحيب من قبل القاده وانصار حزب
بهاراتيا جناه الهندوسي الحاكم مؤسسه قطر
للتربيه والعلوم وتنميه المجتمع تنتقد
قرار اداره جامعه تكساس اي اند ام
الامريكيه باغلاق حرامها الجامعي في قطر
وترى بانها خطوه مدفوعه بحمله تضليل
للاضرار بمصالحها وقالت جامعه تكساس اي ان
ام ان القرار جاء بسبب ما وصفته بتزايد
عدم الاستقرار في الشرق الاوسط الى
اللقاء